having your sights there Dennis Raba
have one of the most exciting guys in
our game today John you like going up
the chimney to get that smoke but it's
All-Star Weekend how much fun you ready
to have uh a lot of fun man obviously
you know it's a blessing to be here
honored to be here got a lot of credit
in my work uh just ready you know they
enjoy this moment with you know a lot of
times they got but how much fun to see
the fans come support you guys in this
practice atmosphere all right big time
Big Time showing
um definitely you know thankful for the
support
um you gotta you know come put on the
show for them I got to get your take on
now KD being the West you say you're not
worried about the west but now the
Memphis excuse me the Phoenix Suns are
going to be coming at you guys uh I'm
ready I'm ready so I need to hear I'm
ready hey guys John said he's ready you
see that Grill you better be ready
that's show Grill is what that is wow
Reggie Reggie
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean I was debating whether to wear
glasses or not today I didn't know the
grill was in play that was see I mean
you gotta love Johnson rookie mistake on
your end you got to know that these
players the lights are on come on man
hey let's oh there you go look at this I
mean come on show Grill I mean listen we
talk about the mountain look at the
earlobe it's like a goodness that's a
mortgage
serious basketball talk here we've seen
all these players from